as a gay public figure just coming at
any friend that I know that is gay yeah
coming out is a huge thing massive
massive and these are people who aren't
known who aren't recognized who are
worried about being judged within their
own communities and I don't know that we
live in a country that's incredibly
accepting yeah welcoming at all for what
you had to do yeah like I'm just saying
because you were on television or
because you're or who you are yeah
everything seems to be and I I'm just
telling you this as a parent seems to be
under such a um a microscope then I
would be really scared to have my child
go through that was that a that would be
harder for was it harder for you do you
think because of who you are and who you
work for and what you do I never
understood the microscope that I was
under until now I'm I mean I'm not much
older but at at 16 you know I thought
like I'm 16 I'm an adult I'm mature and
now I look at I'm only four years older
and I was like dude you were a child you
know what I mean and you're going to say
that in four years I'm going say that in
four years yes exactly um I mean thing
is is I I never felt like I could mess
up or I could screw up or I could do
something wrong because I never was
putting on a show you know I never have
played a character I mean I've played a
few like mini TV roles here and there
but like Jo Jo siwa was never a
character or I mean it was a brand but
it was me you know what I mean so so
it's authentic it was very authentic and
so there was no like all right cameras
are off I'm going to go drink and party
with my friends at 16 it was like all
right cameras are off I'm going to go
edit this video hang out with my family
I know but you you're doing things now
really your sound like she was ever
worried about the criticism right like
maybe the first little bit Yeah but we
when you talked about coming down the
stairs after the first time you were on
the show and you go all these people
hate me and they're voting me off that's
only just Amplified by everything in
your life even a relationship now is
microscop everybody's business talked
about everyone's business and it's
people don't realize that I'm human you
know what I mean I think they realize
that but they but they don't treat me
like it I mean I mean listen I'm sure
you both can relate like people people
see your life and people see who you're
with on the internet and they think that
is your whole entire life and I'm like
no dude that's literally the 10 seconds
of my 24-hour day that I showed you but
you also promote that don't you have
like there what did you call it what was
it lopia oh hell yeah we saw that on
another podcast talking about it yeah we
saw you talking about that I was do not
that you promote it but like that it's
something that like it seems like your
personal life is very on on display it's
so on display and I've never I think I I
if we're talking about the same podcast
I I spoke about this in there I never
cared about my life being on display
because it was my life like it's just
it's kind of all I know it's who I am
and it is what it
[Music]
is